8:00
will be at 8. So
starting tomorrow will be at 5:30
and
will be at 8:00 inshall
I write the times and then I forget what
the dead thing I wrote.
[Silence]
Huh?
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of
yesterday we were discussing the subject
of the
the
conditions or the stipulations in a
person that make salah obligatory upon
this person.
And the author mentions for us.
He says salah is obligatory upon each
Muslim
over the age of puberty
who is sane.
And
remember this is for obligation.
This doesn't mean that these is the only
qualifying descriptions
for
a valid salah. Someone who is
under the age of puberty can make salah
and this salah may be valid and it will
be rewarding. But we're speaking about
obligation.
upon whom is obligatory.
Then he mentions a narration on the
authority of Ali
who narrates that the prophet Sam
says
A narration in
on the authority of Ali that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said the pen
of accountability has been lifted
from upon three types of people. The
person who is sleeping until he awakes.
the child until he reaches the age of
puberty and the insane until his sanity
returns to him.
Then he mentions
a an exception which is regarding
salah and a child under the age of
puberty. He says
for
[Silence]
He then mentions an erration
regarding a ruling and that ruling is
that a person who has a child that is
able to reaching the age of discrepancy
it's called the age of discrepancy
right which is referred to in Arabic
as
a
is a different age the scholars
have differed on the exact age of a
person who is of the age of discrepancy.
But really there is no set age for a
tame right. Children are different and
they arrive at their their mental
capacities at different rates.
usually
it every child by the age of seven has
reached the age of discrepancy.
Every child by the age of seven has
what is a tame? What is the age of
discrepancy? It's when a child is able
to hold the concepts of right and wrong.
Able to hold the concepts of left and
right. Able to understand the
difference between appropriate and
inappropriate.
able to hold an intention for salah
right I am praying this is my salah and
so
this age is different from child
to child it could be at the age of four
could be at the age of five six but
usually by the age of seven all children
have arrived at this age this age of he
then mentions a narration on the
authority of Shu who narrates ates that
his father narrated from his grandfather
who says that the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said,
"Command your children with prayer at
the age of seven and
physically reprimand them for it
for failing to pray at the age of 10 and
separate them in their places of
sleep." And what's meant by separate
them in their places of sleep doesn't
necessarily mean they have to be in
separate rooms of the house. It just
means that each child has his own
blanket that he covers with has his
own place of sleeping, his own bed or
his own mattress. This is what is
meant honestly.
you know different cultures have
different
ways of
sleeping you know arrangements for
children and parents for instance when I
was a kid growing up everybody slept we
only had one room anyways the whole
house was just one room but that's the
same place that we slept so everybody
slept in the same room the parents the
children, the little children, everybody
slept in the same room. Each person had
his own you know mattress and and
blanket and we all slept at the same
time. We all woke up at the same time.
We all woke up together
and you know it it changes based on
different cultures.
western culture,
American culture is extremely radically
different than that and it's much colder
honestly. , usually a child, a baby,
as soon as it's a baby, it's given its
own room, its own crib. And this,
whether this is healthy or not is, you
know, a matter of contention. But the
point is is that, , once children
reach at the most the age of 10, they
should not be sleeping under the same
cover together. They should be separate,
have their own places of sleeping. And
this narration has been collected by Abu
Dani.
Tomorrow inshallah we will begin
discussing
which is the times for prayer. The time
for
and the various times when does the
start time when is the end time? What
are the indicators of these times
inshallah? And this is the first
condition of the nine conditions of
prayer. Nine conditions of prayer. This
is the first one.
[Silence]
No worries.